(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre a existência
da taxa de ocupação.
O que é taxa de ocupação?
Taxa de ocupação é um valor devido pelo
devedor fiduciante ao credor fiduciário desde o momento
que o credor fiduciário consolida a propriedade em
seu nome até o momento da efetiva emissão
na posse em favor do credor fiduciário.
Como isso se aplica para o arrematante de
um leilão excrediticial?
A gente já falou aqui, em momento anterior
do curso, que o arrematante se subroga no
lugar do credor fiduciário.
E o que significa se subrogar no lugar
do credor?
Significa nada mais que o arrematante vai ficar
no lugar daquele credor.
Ele vai ser o novo agente daquela relação
que existia.
Então, o arrematante, a partir da data do
leilão, faz jus a receber essa taxa de
ocupação.
E aqui uma observação importante.
A lei diz que o credor fiduciário tem
direito a receber essa taxa de ocupação desde
a data da consolidação da propriedade em seu
nome.
Para o caso do arrematante, isso aí não
vai ser devido desde a data da consolidação
da propriedade em seu nome, e sim da
data do efetivo leilão.
O entendimento é que se o arrematante só
pudesse receber depois da consolidação da propriedade em
seu nome, o banco receberia um valor que
não era mais dele por direito.
Afinal de contas, a relação do banco com
o devedor fiduciário encerra no momento do leilão,
porque ele já recebeu o valor da arrematação
para quitar aquela dívida de financiamento que estava
em aberto do contrato de alienação fiduciária.
Então, fique com isso em mente.
O arrematante faz jus a receber desde a
data do leilão.
Não precisa efetivamente ter o registro da propriedade
em seu nome ainda.
Esse registro vai acontecer um pouco depois.
A lei diz que a taxa de ocupação
corresponde a 1% do valor que o
próprio contrato de alienação fiduciária estipulou para o
imóvel caso acontecesse um leilão.
Então, recapitulando.
A lei diz que no primeiro leilão extrajudicial,
o imóvel vai com o valor que o
próprio contrato de alienação fiduciária estipulou para o
imóvel caso acontecesse um leilão, ou pelo valor
venal para fim de TBI, o que fosse
maior.
Então, esse valor que o próprio contrato de
alienação fiduciária estipulou para o primeiro leilão vai
ser a base para calcular a taxa de
ocupação.
Então, a taxa de ocupação vai corresponder a
exatamente 1% do valor que o contrato
estipulou para o imóvel.
Então, aqui no exemplo hipotético, vamos falar que
você arrematou o imóvel e que o contrato
de alienação fiduciária deixou ali que expressa que
aquele imóvel custaria R$ 500 mil.
Você, como arrematante, vai fazer jus a essa
taxa de ocupação.
A taxa de ocupação, nesse caso, seria 1
% de R$ 500 mil, seria R
$ 5 mil.
O que é a taxa de ocupação, então?
A taxa de ocupação nada mais é que
uma espécie de aluguel que o devedor que
está ocupando aquele imóvel vai ter que pagar
ao arrematante da data do leilão até a
efetiva emissão na posse.
Como que esse valor vai ser cobrado?
A gente falou que na desocupação de um
imóvel em leilão extrajudicial, o primeiro passo recomendado
é que o arrematante tente um acordo com
o devedor, com quem está ocupando aquele imóvel,
para que essa desocupação ocorra de forma amigável,
que não seja necessário recorrer ao Poder Judiciário.
Mas a gente também falou que caso não
seja possível um acordo amigável, o arrematante vai
ter que recorrer ao Poder Judiciário através da
chamada ação de emissão na posse.
Então, o requerimento da taxa de ocupação também
vai existir nessa ação de emissão na posse.
Eu deixei o modelo da ação lá na
aula de desocupação e se você observar atentamente,
você vai ver que lá naquele modelo também
já consta o pedido da taxa de ocupação.
Como é que vai ocorrer esse processo de
desocupação?
Vamos recapitular aqui.
Vai ter um pedido liminar que o juiz
vai deferir e o ocupante vai ter 60
dias para desocupar aquele imóvel de forma voluntária.
Caso chegue ao final desse prazo de 60
dias e não ocorra desocupação voluntária, aí vai
acontecer a desocupação forçada, realizada por um oficial
de justiça.
Isso tudo, obviamente, tem um procedimento, tem um
prazo.
Então, o juiz deferiu eliminar 60 dias.
O ocupante não realizou a desocupação voluntária, vai
ter um novo requerimento para que seja feita
a desocupação forçada por um oficial de justiça.
Até o oficial de justiça comparecer naquele imóvel,
também vai passar mais algum tempo.
Vamos supor aqui, num exemplo hipotético, que passa
mais um mês.
Depois, o oficial de justiça vai comparecer lá,
então, e vai realizar a desocupação forçada.
Vamos supor, no nosso caso hipotético, que desde
a data da distribuição até a efetiva desocupação,
passaram ali quatro meses.
Mas antes da distribuição do processo, o arrematante
demorou ali um mês para regularizar a documentação
em seu nome.
Então, seria o tempo do processo mais o
tempo anterior ao processo.
Todo esse tempo é devido à taxa de
ocupação.
No nosso exemplo hipotético aqui, cinco meses.
Ao final do processo, o juiz vai deferir
realmente a taxa de ocupação, e aí vai
ser necessário calcular quantos meses aquele ocupante ficou
ali de forma indevida.
E aí vai acontecer uma conta simples de
multiplicação, que é pegar o valor da taxa
de ocupação mensal, que é 1% do
que o contrato de alienação fiduciária estipulou para
preço do imóvel caso acontecesse um leilão, pelo
número de meses que aquele ocupante ficou de
forma indevida no imóvel que o arrematante arrematou
em leilão extrajudicial.
Lembre sempre, então, que a taxa de ocupação
corresponde a 1% do valor do contrato
de alienação fiduciária estipulou para aquele imóvel e
essa taxa é devida mensalmente.
Então corresponde a 1% ao mês.
Uma observação muito importante, não faz sentido você
falar em taxa de ocupação caso você realize
um acordo de desocupação amigável.
Por que não faz sentido?
Eu falei lá na aula de desocupação que
é interessante um acordo até mesmo que você
ofereça alguma prestação pecuniária para quem está ocupando
aquele imóvel, que isso aí pode ser o
pagamento de uma mudança, o pagamento de um
primeiro aluguel, o que escala seu critério.
Pode ser que você entenda também que só
um prazo, ali naquele caso, é razoável.
Então você pode conceder só um prazo ali
de, por exemplo, 30 dias para desocupar aquele
imóvel sem oferecer nada em troca.
Mas caso você realize um acordo, não faz
sentido você falar para a pessoa que está
ocupando, olha, eu deixo você ficar aí 60
meses, você desocupa com tranquilidade, mas nesses 60
meses você me deve a taxa de ocupação
que é 1% do valor que estava
no contrato de alienação fiduciária e corresponde a
tal valor.
Por que não faz sentido isso?
Isso vai ser um fator de desestímulo para
aquela pessoa não faça um acordo de desocupação
amigável.
Afinal de contas, ela pode pensar que se
ela tem que pagar, que ela vai esperar
a ordem do juiz, porque ela vai ter
que pagar de qualquer jeito, então ela espera
uma ordem judicial e enrola ali enquanto dá
para ela desocupar.
O acordo tem que ser algo vantajoso para
as duas partes.
Qual vai ser a vantagem para o arrematante?
Aquilo que a gente falou na aula de
desocupação, não ter que recorrer ao poder judiciário,
não precisar pagar um advogado e outras coisas
do tipo.
Qual vai ser o benefício para quem está
ocupando aquele imóvel?
Um prazo estabelecido ali para que ele possa
desocupar e realmente que ele não tenha que
pagar nenhuma taxa de desocupação, que ele também
não tem que contratar um advogado para se
defender nessa ação de emissão na posse.
Então fique com isso em mente, caso você
realize um acordo de desocupação, não fale em
taxa de ocupação, porque isso aí seria um
fator de desestímulo para que o acordo fosse
realizado.
Então só recapitulando, a taxa de ocupação é
devida para o arrematante desde a data do
leilão até a data da efetiva emissão na
posse e corresponde a 1% ao mês
do valor que o contrato de relação judiciária
estipulou para aquele imóvel caso acontecesse um leilão.
O arrematante, para cobrar essa taxa, vai ter
que fazer o pedido ao juiz na própria
ação de emissão na posse.
Esse pedido já está dentro do modelo de
ação de emissão na posse que eu deixei
lá na aula de desocupação do imóvel.
Basta você voltar lá o modelo que você
vai ver que já está lá tudo certinho
com esse pedido da taxa de desocupação.